Stolpunkt. Stolpunkt ist so eine Sache, ist die zweite Umfall hauptursache beim
Leitschenfliegen ist in Schirm, am vorwärts fliegen Hindern, Einflug in die Thermik
oder in der Thermikfliegen, einfach zu starkes Anbremsen und man ist zunahe an dieser
Stolgeschwindigkeit herangekommen und merkt das Ganze nicht und Stoltern unabsichtlich
den Schirm, das in niedriger Höhe, wenn natürlich fatal und in großer Höhe muss man
einfach das Ganze vielleicht schon mal durchgespielt haben und kennen. Wir haben es auch schon
oft an die Prüfungssam besprochen. Stolpunkt ist jetzt der Punkt, ihr kennt das Ganze,
also um Bremsen ziehen, sehr tief ziehen, bis das Schirm eigentlich nicht mehr vorwärts fliegt,
sondern erst einmal in diesem Sackflug übergeht und nachher in den Rückwärtsflug nach hat
Resultieren gehen könnte. Der Sackflug ist dieser Übergang und jetzt braucht der Schirm
am Sackflugang gekommen, einfach ein ganz klare Zeichen soll es wieder nach vorne gehen oder
soll es nach hinten rückwärts gehen. Der Stolpunkt, der kündigte natürlich auf
verschiedene Atembeisen an, wir können das Ganze einmal über die Bremse spüren, also über
den Druck spüren, ihr tief an mir die Bremse ziehen, um so stärker wird der Druck, sind wir
am Stolpunkt angekommen, lässt der Druck, dieser starke Druck, den wir da unten hatten, schlagartig
nach. Also wie aus der Pistole geschossen hat, da plötzlich gar kein Druck mehr pein, Sack,
müssen da mit den Händen sofort nach oben gehen oder aber ihr könnt das Ganze visuell betrachten,
das heißt, wenn ihr den Schirm anschaut, ist der am Anfang noch schön breit gefüllt, ihr
stärker in der Bremse zieht, um so näher kommen wir dann Richtung Stolpunkt, wenn wir da
angekommen sind, dann fliegt der Schirm nicht mehr vorwärts, sondern ist im Sackflug, aber die
Spannweite vom Schirm ist so über Fliegel Ende bis Fliegel Ende noch gegeben, das heißt die
Streckung ist noch da, aber jetzt trägt die Luftmasse von unten auf den Schirm drauf, das heißt
ihr könnt sehen, wie sich das Untersegel so nach oben hin ausbeut, so richtige Bauchungen macht,
das ist ein Zeichen dafür,, dass ihr am Stolpunkt angekommen seid. Und diese zwei Faktoren, die
muss man so ein bisschen unabhängig voneinander nehmen, das kann sein, ihr seht das zuerst visuell
am Schirm und spürt erst eine Sekunde später an der Bremse, was zum Beispiel auch schon ein großes
Problem sein könnte, oder aber umgekehrt ihr spürt zuerst auf der Bremse bevor es am Schirm wahrnehmen
ist, falls die Hände einfach nach oben, wenn ihr denkt, wo jetzt will, aber schon eigentlich
nah dran, oder für mich einfach schon zunah dran, endlich hoch, das definieren wir dann nix.
Ich sage euch dann schon, ja, da hat noch ein bisschen was gefehlt, dann könnt ihr das
abspeichern, ja auch ein bisschen was hat auch gefehlt. Also für den Stolpunkt suchen müssen
mit beide Bremsen relativ weit nach unten ziehen und damit mir da ein gutes Gefühl haben,
da hätte ich euch auch empfehlen, die Bremse diesen Heidenschlag zu widtern. Eventuell sind
die Steuere so lang, also gerade über dem Seen meistens bei so ruhiger Luftmasse, kann es sogar sein,
dass man vielleicht sogar noch mal ein zweites Mal wie können müssen. Aber nehmen wir jetzt mal nur
diese eine halbe Wicken und rein, ihr schaut den Schirm gut an und ihr zieht die Bremsen ganz langsam,
sie mitgeschweiten nach oben, nehmt auch mal wahr, wie dieser Steuertruck zunehmt, also auch schon
die ersten 20, 30 Zentimeter langsam ziehen, immer weiter ziehen, aber langsam hier im Anschach beobachten,
dann merkt er, der Steuertruck, der wird jetzt schon deutlicher, der jetzt ziemlich hart und wird
sich macht, der Steuertruck ist seit am Steuertruck angekommen. Wenn ihr am Steuertruck entfernt und
ihr bleibt in dieser Position behachen, dann geht es in den Stol, also in den Flyback über und das
geht es natürlich zu vermeiden, das wollen wir nicht, wir wollen jetzt nur mal diesen Steuertruck erfüllen,
wo ist denn etwa, ist er hier, ist er hier, der kann unterschiedlichen Stellen sein, vor allem wenn
wir thermik fliegen, dann kann der auch mal da oben sein, wichtig ist einfach immer ein Händlerruck,
wenn jetzt das Gefühl habt, ich bin dran, ein Händlerruck, wie gesagt, um zwei bis zwei Händlerruck. Und
Schirm dabei anschauen, das heißt, vielleicht habt ihr es schon visuell ausmachen können, okay,
ich würde zwar noch kein Nachlassen auf der Bremse, aber ich sehe es visuell, man schirmt, da
braucht sich das um die Siga aus beiden Händlerruck, immer zügig hoch. Was können wir machen, wenn man
im Sackflug dringend sind? Beispielsweise, Besteuze langsam ausgeleitet, hatte ich einmal mit einem
sehr sehr leichten Mädeln, den Besteuze langsam ausgeleitet, ich habe im Sackflug hängen
geblieben. Das heißt, die Hände sind schon oben, wir können nach vorne gehen, zu den A-Guten,
mit ziehen die A-Guten lassen sie wieder los, das wäre die Ausleitung für den Sackflug. Also
riecht ich zehn, um wieder zu wissen. Und dann sollte der G-Rum spätisch dran fahren.